more details about the new uh iPad Air 2
and it will allow for burst selfies so
not only can you take selfies you can
take a lot of selfies in a row I mean
how cool is that kill
me I'm sorry I don't think we need
Tablet selfies to be that much
encouraged Touch ID faster Wi-Fi dual
microphones okay Touch ID is something
that has become a real like uh a real
saving throw on the bigger iPhones right
it's easier to unlock them it's easier
to get at stuff when you're
authenticating security is very
important right now especially to Apple
um having Touch ID integrated with apps
like one password and dash lane is
really big deal faster Wi-Fi is very
good especially because people are using
these as laptop Replacements um thinner
they were saying you can stack two of
these on top of each other and it's
still thinner than an original iPad Paul
how you feeling are you still feeling
me oh I'm still meh so yeah I know it
hasn't changed very much you know this
is exactly what we thought we would see
and you know we're seeing it and we're
seeing it some was saying I just saw in
my in my Twitter stream about how
they're going on relentlessly about thin
as if that's the only thing that matters
in the universe with respect to tablets
you know none of this none of this
changes the fundamental problem Apple
has which is that you know the the the
purchasing cycle for tablets is much
slower than phones and there's this been
the real loss of momentum in the tablet
market and making these devices thinner
isn't really going to change all of that
it doesn't change the fundamental
problem that it has you know in that
market and the thing that worries me in
particular is that all of this just
reminds me of what cook is good at at
which is to say optimization making
things thinner improving battery life
and what he's bad at which is you know
really saying doing stuff that makes you
say oh my goodness Apple's doing what
that's that's crazy you're not ever
going to get that from cook but you are
going to get thinner devices and longer
battery life the watch doesn't
count no I don't think it does I think
the you know the watch is one of these
things that you know was sort of a a
natural extension of what they did
that's I don't think anyone well maybe
people are maybe there are people are
really excited about about it I mean
it's into a category that seemed largely
stale for a long long time you know so I
guess it's more at the margin but most
of what he's doing in the products is
more just saying here's another Natural
Evolution here's another Natural
Evolution not here's something
altogether new that can really Drive
growth going forward and change the you
know the valuation of the company Joe
you said earlier you know the future of
Apple is bright it's not necessarily
happening at this particular event today
will we see any surprises is there
anything unexpected what what else do
they have for us I think the rumor blogs
are going to have it 100% um we're going
to see iPads yosity iOS 8.1 which they
need to unveil soon because or I guess
they did because iOS 8 was just a
disaster and then um retina IMAX
basically uh you know more to more
geared towards home video editing better
screen resolution John what else what
else is to come yeah I don't think we're
going to see any surprises today uh
Emily but
I but I think you know I do think thin
is is something right it's not uh you
know they're making these products
better they're keeping them at the front
and I uh and and and that's exciting you
know like I said before sometimes it's
Innovation sometimes it's it's Evolution
right I've been using my new thinner
iPhone 6 and I love it it's better it's
fine I mean you know it's a very we're
we're so it's all fine fine I I wish
this thing was great I mean I got this
for Apple pay frankly I mean that
because I switch every year between
Apple and Android but Android's lapping
Apple you're so democratic no I'm just
trying to be able to edit
stuff but but yeah I mean this phone is
is pretty is pretty vanilla and I think
the iPads as an innovation are are
fairly vanilla too that said like every
year if you don't have an iPad it's
probably good to get the new one so
that's good for them all right so Paul
where does Apple go from here if the
iPad is coming becoming a smaller part
of their business though it is still 15
to 20% of
Revenue what what's going to grow is it
all about phones the watch is supposed
to be a niche product you know what else
do they have
it's not clear what they have they more
rapidly ruling things out you know so
this is my disappointment you know when
I gave you example earlier of not buying
some cloud services like Spotify or like
Dropbox and instead ending up in the
completely baffling decision of owning
of owning beats which just you know
makes absolutely no sense and I can't
imagine how that's going to change so
you know there are obvious things they
could have done and should be doing and
yet they're not doing it as they focus
on these you know suboptimization of you
know battery life and thinner iPads it
feels like Dell Circ
1996 you know and people are getting
excited about a couple of more mehz or
gahz of clock speed and it's like wow
they people are disagreeing with you
right here just quickly we only have a
few seconds left I think buying Beats
was buying Jimmy iven and that's
somebody who can negotiate with content
providers and maybe get them a little
leg up in in TV